okay you did not come to play with these
incredible sequins can you tell me a
secret about this dress a secret about
this dress
I feel like a shiny Diamond you are a
shiny Diamond thank you you're a shiny
Diamond who has an album coming out at
the end of this month what are you most
excited to give your fans with this
record I am most excited for fans to get
more of an Insight of who Chloe is as a
human being and who is that
a girl who loves music in the ocean and
who has been broken down a lot but I'm
really good at hiding it and he's
finding strength and power in her pain
is there a lyric on the album that
speaks to that that you're just like
really excited for your fans to be able
to relate to
yes
um it's called make it look easy and
what's the lyric make it look easy make
it look easy I mean then you do queen
you're out here dancing and singing and
writing and producing I mean being a
woman in music someone might look at you
and say God Chloe does it I want to do
it too what is the best piece of advice
that you can offer well just hearing
that that brings a smile on my face
because no one knows everything that
goes on behind the scenes so I'm just so
grateful for this moment I'm so happy to
be here with this in this frequency of
such incredible strong women and like
you said I'm just here as a fan and a
supporter and I'm here to present one of
my really great friends so lotto and I'm
so proud of her so I'm happy to be here
for her and all of the incredible women
and Rosalia with producer of the Year
award and says women who produced baby
yes so I am just I'm here to soak it all
up and to be inspired and hope to be
here next year as a solo artist yes
Queen yes and until then you're going
out on tour yes I am what can you tease
or describe about the live experience of
seeing Chloe live it'll definitely be an
experience it it will never be the same
each night because changing it up well
no not in terms of set but I just let
myself be free and I'm so excited to
connect with my incredible fans and you
know us sing the songs together really
up until the first date of the show
there's probably about 10 days for them
to learn the songs so it'll be quickly
people yeah yeah but it's like they'll
be able to feel me and feel why I wrote
certain songs and I'll be able to
explain it on stage and you know really
connect with them so that's why I'm so
excited to do this because I made this
project for myself and to heal myself
and I hope it heals others too is it a
full-on spectacle is it a therapy
session I mean what should we know about
going to the show it's a therapy session
for sure it takes you up and down all
throughout my mind it's a roller coaster
and you know just because there's some
sad songs and content and lyrics sad
girls can have too so I'm so excited and
I executive produced it and I produce
every song on there I think except for
two or three and it was just such a fun
experience I'm so proud of you thank you
foreign